this tastes like a bath and Bodyworks
gone wrong this pizza makes me sad hi my
name is destiny my name is Stanley and
today we'll be guessing which pizza is
vegan I love meat I like pepperoni I'll
do some sausage here and there like
Canadian bacon I would say I eat a lot
of meats if I eat a pizza it's probably
like the meat lover pizza I'm pretty
sure I've never had vegan pizza so we'll
see what happens here
my relationship with me it's a long
dedicated relationship there was a time
when I did try to test out being
vegetarian for like a month or so and I
liked it was hell I went vegan for a
month actually it was fine it was great
but I still can't give up meat I think
I've had vegan pizza before and it was
really good it was actually so good that
I couldn't tell that it was vegan pizza
I feel like I'll be able to tell pretty
easily especially like vegan cheese is
kind of funky that's true so we'll see
all right well yeah oh gosh my head is
still too fat all right I am
sufficiently blind same mmm smells like
it smells like traditional pizza okay
that's good Oh mm-hmm
I know this pizza we grew up on these
hmm it reminds me of like pizza you
would got for like high school lunch it
reminds me of Bagel Bites I can already
tell it's like a frozen pizza that's a
thing I think this pizzas real yeah it's
very real pizza this is not vegan I'm
pretty sure we had these as kids so I
don't think this is the vegan one I
can't really taste the cheese but I feel
like it did nothing throwing me off with
it it is a very like low quality paint
that yeah I mean it's pretty cheap
really cheap so like you probably can't
taste the cheese but it's on there this
is a good dog I'm almost done with it
okay but do you think that there's
actually meat on here I mean I feel like
I don't know right now I'm not getting
any hunches that this is vegan I'll be
able to get a better sense once I
actually tried the other pizzas and kind
of compare
mm-hmm but for now I'm gonna say this
one is the vegan one I think I disagree
I think this one is meat I think this
one have meat I think this is not a
great pizza but I'm pretty sure it's
still a normal pizza I can't really
taste the cheese the meat though to me
sufficiently tastes like bad sausage
seems legit
the real thing the real bad thing what a
gigantic slice from the smell I think
this one is cream based oh it smells
like garlic yes all right let's see is
this just like a plain cheese people
like there's no big meat on this I feel
weird like touching the back I got a
weird texture thingy like almost like a
a gooey slimy something maybe this is
the vegan pizza because that's what like
vegan cheese is like sometimes I don't
know okay let me take another bite this
one's a little bit trickier I'm leaning
towards this is also not vegan it
doesn't taste like your standard like
pepperoni I don't know if it's a white
sauce or like oh yeah I guess that's
what the thing is it's not a tomato
sauce it's not a normal pizza but it's
still a dairy product yeah I still think
it's non vegan yeah actually I think
this piece is really good it's really
flavorful I can't really taste cheese I
do taste some kind of sauce but it's
really good it's like yeah oh yeah this
is a vegan cheese
I feel like sticks to my mouth in this
weird way that only happens when I'm
eating this like vegan cheese but I also
want to say that this is really good I
was just gonna say it's good I love it
because like I'm someone who loves
garlic bread like when I'm at all Goethe
I'm like endless breadsticks I agree
with you I think the texture of the
toppings is a little different than what
I'm used to but I'm also confused
because like I think it's playing well
with the crust so it's like oh
everything makes sense is complementing
each other to make it like taste good
because it does taste good but there are
just little things about
make me believe that it is vegan not
sure yet though I'll need the final one
to make my final decision
[Music]
you smell I can get some smokey funky
smells yep this pizza makes me sad oh my
god it's so gross they're so gross it's
so thin it's so dry and then when I feel
the top of the crust
it feels humongous and I think this is
so bad so where's this flavor oh you
know what I think this is I think this
is still a normal pizza I think it's
just a different cheese I object
really oh my god I just swallowed it
that is wrong yeah this tastes like a
bath and Bodyworks gone wrong like it's
a whole flowery and like weird and like
chemically reminds me of real cheese
like real real cheese like people who
like goat cheese cheese you know I think
it's still normal cheese but I feel like
it's almost like a blue cheese or
something like that and I think this is
like a funky cheese funky yeah this
could be like a gourmet pizza and we
hate it are you taking another bite I
just want to be like is it seriously
this bad like I'm in disbelief how could
pizza be bad I just don't like it I
would not buy it I don't want to even
take another bite I think that's the
vegan one really I am less inclined to
think that
okay I think option two is the vegan one
I agree after trying all three I think
number two is the vegan option I
definitely think the third one is the
vegan one I feel like I'm leaning more
towards the second one beating being the
vegan one and then number two is I was
right oh my goodness that was really
good that's really bad out of all three
this was the most delicious one like it
was really good number two of my
favorite number two is by far my hair
like flavor-wise is like just kiss it
look delightful I'm not shocked because
I feel like my thoughts on vegan pizza
would be that like the cheese would be
kind of funny and like the whatever else
on there that isn't vegetables would be
kind of funky but this pizza was like
really flavorful it smelled really good
the cheese tasted really good
I normally probably would not order a
vegan pizza like at all but after having
this I probably would like that was
really I'm still like my mind is like
still blown that was really good I was
not surprised by how good the vegan
pizza was I feel like vegan alternatives
are often very delicious and yeah it
didn't disappoint what I get vegan pizza
instead of like traditional pizza uh
still know as much as I love this flavor
I would still want like sausage on it
like I would still want bacon or
something on top of it but it's good to
know that there are these like
alternatives are honestly just as yummy
if not yummy ER and you could have it
and still make like a choice I is better
for the planet I have nothing to add
[Laughter]
[Music]